momento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América me acompaña en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas
noches vamos a hablar de las
criptomonedas que pasan por lo que
muchos están llamando el cripto invierno
de qué estamos hablando Jorge bueno Y es
que está caída de las principales
criptomonedas coincide con el desplome
también de los índices bursátiles de
Estados Unidos en los últimos meses los
activos digitales han caído presionados
por muchos factores externos como la
guerra en Ucrania la fortaleza del dólar
y la subida de los tipos de interés que
emprenden los bancos centrales del mundo
para tratar de contener la inflación las
criptomonedas tuvieron su momento de
Gloria durante la pandemia ya que fueron
vistas como una opción para protegerse
en tiempos de incertidumbre económica
pero ahora son golpeadas por el auge de
los rendimientos de los bonos del tesoro
de Estados Unidos y el temor de una
desaceleración económica Global en los
próximos meses el bitcoin Opera
alrededor de los 19 mil dólares con lo
que acumula una caída en su valor de
casi el 60% en 2022 un desplome del 71%
desde su máximo histórico registrado en
noviembre del año pasado según los datos
de bloomberg la otra criptomoneda de
mayor popularidad es ethereum que Sigue
los pasos del bitcoin el sector de las
criptomonedas ha perdido casi dos
billones de dólares en valor de Mercado
y la firma especializada en blockchain
glass Note calificó Esta caída como el
momento más profundo y oscuro pero en
realidad la pregunta es estamos frente
al final de este Mercado o se trata de
otra crisis como las anteriores que ha
superado se lo preguntamos al empresario
Argentina Silvina muchini presidente y
productor ejecutiva del programa unicor
Hunter
yo creo que estamos viviendo una
Revolución o una crisis Revolución
similar a la que vivimos si te acuerdas
por el año 2000 con el Boom o con el
Birds cuando reventó La burbuja de
internet
y esto que le llaman el cripto invierno
tiene mucho de semejanza con con esto no
creo que se haya llegado al piso y no
creo tampoco ni remotamente que se haya
llegado al techo ni con bitcoin ni con
todas las otras monedas porque pues lo
que creo Es que bitcoin allanó el camino
para crear una nueva categoría de
monedas trae una nueva categoría al
mercado de capitales pero no es el único
jugador Así que creo que vamos a esperar
muchos saltos pero también muchos más
bajos y picos de rebote como todo vuelve
los ciclos se repiten Jorge pero pese a
Esta caída el auge de las criptomonedas
es tal que por ejemplo en Estados Unidos
están estudiando crear un Banco Central
específicamente para ellas Bueno de
hecho la administración del presidente
estadounidense y Joe biden lanzará un
grupo de trabajo integrado por distintas
agencias que apoyen los esfuerzos de las
reserva federal y consideren las
implicaciones de crear una divisa
digital respaldada por el Banco Central
de ese país no son los primeros
recientemente también la Unión Europea
presentó una propuesta de normativa para
regular lo que ellos denominan el
salvaje oeste criptográfico y es que
mucho del riesgo de los criptoactivos
está vinculado a la no regulación y el
respaldo de estos activos digitales algo
que los emprendedores ya están
trabajando según nuestra invitada
qué va a pasar es que va a haber monedas
inteligentes en escala nosotros estamos
haciendo eso de otras compañías también
como avocado cohen respaldado por la
industria de El abocado otras compañías
respaldadas por la industria de la
minería y otros tantos más donde lo que
hacen es que toman lo mejor de Los dos
mundos lo mejor del mundo tradicional
donde el respaldo hace que puedas tener
un piso pero también lo mejor del mundo
del blockchain de las criptomonedas que
hace que el techo pueda hacer lo que
representa en valor el mercado es decir
lo que dice el mercado que que van
entonces va a haber monedas respaldadas
por Fiat Garden sí que para mí como
vimos el dólar se achicas se encogen
monedas respaldadas por bienes que tal
vez no crecen como el antes era el
trueque te cambio una gallina por una
bolsa de maíz luego la sal de cambio una
bolsa de sal por determinada cosa luego
evolucionó y creo que el dinero va a
seguir
funcionando y que este dinero sin lugar
a dudas va a estar anclado en tecnología
como la tecnología de blockchain que ya
obviamente
muchísimamente gente conoce pero que va
a tener un modelo de negocio distinto
porque tiene que tener por un lado
capacidad de almacenamiento
almacenamiento de valor Pero por otro
capacidad de transacciones es decir
usarse como dinero y es la transición
lógica pasamos también en el medio por
dinero a través de internet Como por
ejemplo lo que uno hace cuando le manda
plata a sus amigos por un teléfono y
ahora esta es la evolución y la
transición
esperada y tradicional y creemos que
Esto va a ser masivo porque estamos
redefiniendo Cómo se representa el valor
Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización del mundo económico
ponemos punto final a la economía aquí
en directo América a continuación el
debate
[Música]